après mant la jolie Saint-Germain en la
c'est autour de Versailles d'être
victime du plan de restructuration de la
Banque de France la succursale devrait
disparaître d'ici à 2016 un plan qui est
sorti sans négociation sans sans
discussion avec les organisations
syndicales et qui est très violent qui
entraînerait la fermeture d'énormément
de succursales monsieur noyer dans son
communiqué dit que ces succursales ne
fermeraient pas des succursales comme
Versailles qui ont actuellement une
soixantaine d'employés se retrouveraient
à devenir des coquill
entre 4 et 10 agents ces quelques agents
continuerai à travailler sur les 4000
dossiers de surendettement traités
annuellement autre fait surprenant pour
Karine Martin c'est la seule succursale
de grande couronne en île-de-fance qui
fermerait ses portes nous on fait partie
justement des choses assez
incompréhensible sachant que la barre
était fixée au hauteur de 3000
entreprises côté et que nous on en côte
systématiquement plus de 4000 on ne
comprend pas pourquoi Versailles est
visé par cette mesure on peut pas
comprendre
c'est c'est vraiment inexplicable
l'autre impact se ressentirait sur les
services d'entreprise la Banque de
France note la cotation des entreprise
en clair ell confirment leur
solevabilité aux banques en cas de prêt
sans ce contrôle la viabilité des
banques françaises serait en danger la
direction versaillaise a refusé de
répondre à nos questions les employés de
la succursale ivelinoise doivent se
positionner sur des possibilités de
reclassement entre 2013 et 2015 avant la
fermeture prévue pour